can you run down to the kitchen and your
underpants in the middle of the night of
you're hungry I mean I could I don't
is there any way we could fly Obama to
some golf course halfway around the
world and just leave him there
well RWS surfer girl I think it's a
great idea there was a whole structure
there according to Justice Department
report that indicated both racism and
just a disregard for what law
enforcement supposed to do we're asking
people to sign up for what we're calling
a student aid Bill of Rights
good bye boring presidential radio dress
hello
Dick Cheney spins the hits of the 80s
90s and today sock it to me
I wouldn't be with you here today if I
didn't have something to point